we're going to hear more about the
education white paper you're very keen
to highlight the increase or likely
increase in funding uh returning to 2010
levels by 2024-25
why do you think that's a success
well we had to come through
the financial crisis
and of course
then the pandemic where we've
put 400 billion to work to support jobs
and
the economy
to be able then in the spending review
to
have seven billion being invested in uh
schools in education taking the total
budget for schools alone to 56 but over
56 billion
um so my total budget in the education
department is 86 billion by 24.25
i think that's important which is why
and by the way that seven billion is
front loaded so
four billion of it is uh coming early uh
to make sure that we have the investment
in our schools uh teachers have done an
excellent job to make sure that 99.9 of
schools
um uh opened and remained open through
omicron so that investment is really
important uh it means i hope
we can
complete the journey which is what my
white paper does
of
a family of schools which is all the
evidence suggests that schools that work
together in a family of schools that's
tightly uh managed really well supported
by a strong and underlying strong
high-performing multi-academy trust
deliver better outcomes for the children
i'm very fond of talking about my
background of being the 11 year old who
couldn't speak a word of english but
with parents i had the wherewithal to
push me in and look where i am today i
want the system to work for every child
wherever they are at the right place at
the right time even with those whose
parents don't have the wherewithal or
have no parents that's what the white
paper will do it's a real
ambitious target to make sure every
school in our country is high performing
in that family of schools working
together so let's go back to why you say
that there have been challenges on the
budget of course it's affected every
department but the health budget has
increased by 42.4 percent by 2025 since
2010 the department of education only
2.8
so there is the money there
so what the chancellor's done if you
look actually across government and
health has had a a big uplift because of
the pandemic clearly we had to deal i
was the the vaccine deployment minister
in health at the time um
but education has also now uh caught up
in in the sense that we've got seven
billion going into schools uh we've got
3.8 billion going into skills you see on
my lapel that tl t levels tory leader as
we always say well it's it's it's
actually a fusion between an a level and
a uh
an apprenticeship uh that is what a t
level and we will make them as famous as
a levels um over 80 um universities now
accept t levels or you can go straight
into work as well um so look the
investment is there uh the white paper
outlines how we're going to get there
the first thing you've got to do by the
way the most important thing and the
greatest predictor of outcomes is a
great teacher in the classroom we're
investing a quarter of a billion in half
a million teacher training opportunities
so from the early careers framework to
the initial teacher training to the
later on in life sort of professional
development big investment in teaching a
big
target to take at the moment only
two-thirds of children complete primary
school
with the ability to read write and do
maths to an acceptable level two-thirds
that's not good enough i want to get
that i only spend five grand of people
on well i want to get that to 90 percent
90 we don't spend enough money
so the oecd i had andre schleicher from
the oecd in my office a couple of weeks
ago he said on schools you're right up
in terms of
investment in education um
compared to other oecd countries
that's a good thing
now how that money spent sometimes
because the netherlands consistently
places higher than the uk in world
education rankings they've pledged over
six times the amount of catch-up funding
per pupil in the uk so i've got five
billion as well as seven billion i've
got five billion in catch-up money you
remember when i was doing the vaccines
yeah right i wasn't interested in how
many vaccines we had in the warehouse i
want to know how many we get them
people's arms i've got five billion to
spend on the national tutoring program
as part of that getting those
children with the least time left in
education 16 20 year olds uh 800 million
of that money and of course focusing on
disadvantaged children in primary and
secondary let me get that money into the
system make sure that those
students are getting that additional
help which they are we've got a million
blocks of uh tutoring that have already
been delivered we're gonna deliver
another million by the end of this
school year six million in total by the
end of this parliament
and i i'm will always be
data-driven evidence-driven
i will evaluate and i'll look how far
we've got we're doing well on primary
school reading and maths catch up
we need to do better at secondary
and i'll always go back for more but let
me actually get this right there's no
point having a sort of arms race how
much can i announce i'm spending
i've got to make sure it's actually
working in the system scale is hard in
anything you do but having 10 000
academies already is great i've got 22
000 schools in england i want to
complete that journey but complete it
with quality
you need the money to do that the
catch-ups are kevin collins um he
resigned didn't he um he said uh
the proposal that he presented the
government was for 15 billion pounds
worth of funding why do you think he
resigned well there was clearly a um
a disagreement as to
the the you're taking people on you're
asking to be an expert and then he
presents this report and you ignore him
no no this is i have a lot of time for
kevin collins i worked with him in fact
when i was children and families
minister in the department four years
ago why do you think he resigned but
there was a disagreement over the the
quantum of investment what i'm saying to
you is i've got seven billion uh going
into
investment in schools i've got five
billion on recovery um let me do this
well and i can demonstrate to kevin
collins and the rest of the country how
well we've done on catch-up
tutoring used to be the privilege of
fortunate parents wealthier parents it's
now available to every parent i want
parents watching this program this
morning to ask their schools are they
participating in the national tutoring
program because we want to make sure
that we deliver six million blocks of 15
hours of tutoring for children for
recovery down to the money minister we
have five billion and i'm i'm going to
say 16 billion is what the
catch-ups are says with respect to uh
kevin i don't i'm not interested in in
sort of announcing big numbers i'm just
saying how we're going to spend it to
deliver how interesting announcing big
numbers but we have the big numbers from
the chancellor saying that you know the
big cheers in the house of commons we're
going to take you back up to 2010 levels
um 14 years after we took power
so look the the
how is that successful well i tell you
why because you've we've had to come
through a financial crisis um
if we hadn't taken the tough decisions
then we wouldn't be able to spend the
400 billion 400 billion that the chances
spent protecting jobs protecting
businesses small businesses um making
sure that 14 million people
had that net of protection through the
furlough scheme and then we were hit by
a global pandemic you know but other
departments have that problem as well
and as i said it's chump change what you
get or you're getting compared to the
national health service i hear what you
say about them and needing the money for
the pandemic um let's talk about kids in
schools though when it comes to food you
know a lot of them need to have a hot
meal at school because that's the only
time they get it half a million children
are in absolute poverty
so that i saw the resolution foundation
works i think what you're referring to
um what the chancellor's done um is
earmarked 22 billion for this one year
coming because of the we're in a global
battle okay against inflation what does
that mean it means that your weekly shop
is increasing your utility bills are
increasing 22 billion for one year of
help 9 billion of it is going into
helping people with energy costs he's
already announced that in february
we'll always review that we'll look what
more we can do but part of that this
friday
the
national living wage will increase which
means people get a thousand pounds in
schools i mean i'm sure that you'll be
as appalled as i was to hear about a 14
year old boy in wandsworth who was in
the queue at a food bank collapsed
through hunger and had to be taken to
hospital that that's 21st century
britain come on well that's i agree
that's heartbreaking which is why i'm
saying to you that the money the 22
billion i'm just trying to describe to
you where it's going yeah right 9
billion going towards energy 1 billion
so the chancellor in the
spring statement double the amount going
to local government your question about
onesworth onesworth will know where
those families are that need the most
help the ones that you just described to
me at the food bank or the ones who are
really struggling with their utility
bills acknowledge that you should not
happen which is why he's putting which
is why he doubled the amount going to
local government so they can help those
people
directly uniquely to be able to go to
those households and say look there is
help available for you 22 billion
in one year is a you know a big number
but we're not resting on our laurels
we're not saying job done we're saying
we'll keep an eye on this because
energy prices are volatile at the moment
um there is a global battle against
inflation
in america in europe everywhere but no
school child should go hungry in 20 i
don't disagree with i was the the
minister when i was children who
introduced the holiday activities and
food programme with frank field we
started with 10 million pounds labour
labour absolutely right um it's now
running at 220 million a year and we've
got the funding for the next three years
to continue to deliver holiday
activities and food program we're coming
into a holiday
period now i'm very proud of the work
we've done
on that we continue to support we've
just announced free school meals for uh
children of parents with no recourse to
public funds um which is important to
make sure that
that child doesn't go hungry either so
we're doing a lot of work in this area
in the department the important thing is
education
actually unlocks opportunity you know
it's only when i began to think in the
language you know i remember remember
having to learn and then you know read
and try and speak as well as i can when
i started to think in the language and
the best thing i can do for children is
make sure there's a great teacher uh
with a school that's strong and well
supported in a family of schools
everywhere from noseley to kensington
i don't believe that a child in noseley
is less talented than a child in
kensington right they just don't have
the opportunity and i'm going to deliver
that for you okay but your former
vaccines minister why do you think it's
appropriate
uh to stop you
having free lateral flow tests
so for nhs staff particularly so
the secretary of state for health will
say a bit more on this on the first
of april
on what we're doing on testing um
the important thing to remember is we
have to live with
the virus
our first line of defense is vaccine
he's already announced a further fourth
jab for the most vulnerable uh in
society but i'm talking about lateral
closure i i hear you the second line of
defense is the um therapeutics and the
antivirals which he's had the foresight
started to buy those as well
now in some uh
parts of the economy where we need to
have further
work in terms of testing he will say
more on that
but actually
between vaccine and our radar system the
ability to genome sequence
i think we're in a strong place to now
continue to live with the virus we're
gonna have to live with it i don't know
for how long maybe
five six seven ten years but if people
are going to um
elderly care homes or whatever they need
to have a test in order to go into that
that's 1260 pounds a year something like
that is is the average calculation
that's a tax on caring well he's he'll
say more about um what
will happen on
lateral flow devices on the first of
april but
ultimately we're going to have to live
with this virus it is through the
vaccination program that you're going to
protect populations it's great that you
know the uk population now has very high
levels of antibodies because of the
vaccination program not just the the one
i was responsible for but then the
booster campaign where he delivered so
brilliantly javid and of course now the
fourth jab and the antivirals and
therapeutics we have to get to a place i
think where we transition this virus
from pandemic to endemic we're well on
our way we're probably the first major
economy i mean just watching what's
happening in china you know this idea
where people had a sort of zero covert
strategy is clearly not working it's a
this is a virus that is aerosol
transmitted it is a respiratory virus
it's never going to work the best thing
you can do is protect the population
through vaccination and then continue to
make sure that the protection is there
for the most vulnerable all the time
we're almost out of time but i just
wanted to know what you thought about
what president biden said um did he
misspeak um on at the weekend when he
was talking about regime change in
russia well both the white house and the
president have been clear on this we are
in lockstep with them that is up to the
russian people to decide who governs
them and the uh future
well
i hate but um do you back those words
no i what i would say is up to the
russian people i think russian people
are pretty fed up
not only because they're they're
watching their you know their friends
and some of them have family um uh in
ukraine who've been attacked um by the
putin uh regime clearly war crimes have
been committed because they're targeting
innocent
civilians in civilian areas the deputy
prime minister is working with the
international criminal court to make
sure that that evidence is in place but
i think president biden is right to say
that putin has no place in the ukraine
they have to make sure that they
would draw from ukraine because it's an
illegal invasion of the ukraine i think
he's absolutely right in that
ultimately it's the russian people who
decide who governs them do you agree
that is a butcher
well i think there are war crimes have
been committed in the ukraine no doubt
in my mind the evidence is clear on that
it's right to collect that evidence
because it's also important you know my
family had experience with saddam
hussein
it's important that despots and
dictators uh understand that there will
be a reckoning um and that reckoning
will come through
the international criminal court uh in
the hague as we've seen in bosnia and of
course in other parts of the world it's
really important um
this is not something that um should be
taken lightly that that someone can um
go into a a a country illegally
and start bombing civilians um and and
feel that uh there there is no um
there is no response from the global
community and i think
in many ways
the coming together of the world in this
way has sent a very clear message to any
dictator that they're not going to be
able to get away with in 2022 yeah
absolutely right it's great to see you
as always thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you very much